[Musique]
mystérieux couleurs mates et l'hébreu
the masses qui n'a pas de super pouvoirs
et qui pourtant d'être super mec
batman
je m'appelle max la menace c'est une
vraie menace pour tout le monde super
verbe et j'aurai plein de pouvoir comme
de bagarreur rang des autres
chroniqueurs moins cons ce n'est pas
facile
les téléportations en me téléporter dans
les guerres napoléoniennes nos télés
pour clore là dans les guerres
napoléoniennes et doumeng se sont
inventés et déportés parce que regarder
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
là par exemple je vais mal à cacher de
sao
on
le physique de wonder woman des pouvoirs
bien sûr magnifique parce que chacun
sait pouvoir peut avoir son physique
physique de superman il est d'ailleurs
donc on va donner pouvoir
quel est l'intérêt d'être super fort
super intelligent et que le seul au
monde à le savoir maintenant je préfère
personne ne le sache en avoir et
personne ne sait au moins là je suis
tranquille
[Musique]
lemoine super bowl benjamin castaldi
serait hulk delormeau c'est frankenstein
la chose je vais très morini bosc et
superman
[Musique]
j'ai mer aem kahlo
superman superman son camarade je suis
ton père ces mules ânes suis ton père
bon de zouk machine superman du trot
[Musique]